hello everyone welcome back to
GameSpot's best of 2017 countdown we are
here today about to announce our number
5 game of the year I'm Mike McCarty here
with Peter Brown hello again
jean-luc psyche hello and Ben Janka
hello and we have already announced 5
games I'll go through them really quick
near automatons number 10 what remains
of eath Finch was 9 he'll blades Senna
was sacrificed was 8
Wolfenstein - the new Colossus 7 and
horizon zero dawn was number six which
pissed off absolutely nobody but without
further ado let's jump into a montage
which Dave Jewett over in the UK team
cut for our number 5 game of 2017 I'm
afraid I always before my part so no no
stay and watch though because I'm just
about to create a scene
[Applause]
[Music]
I must even hide my true face beneath an
ever-shifting mask for fear you savages
will attack me
if I don't stop her I don't know who
well
I used to be a slave kept under the
thumb of the master
[Applause]
I was destined to become the next
Emperor
[Music]
[Music]
come here to kill God welcome but
instead
the best
divinity original sin - from Larian
Studios is GameSpot's 2017 number five
game of the year that is uh one of the
PC games that came out this latter half
of the year that none of us could stop
talking about one of our three ten out
of ten yeah we had a free lunch to do
that review and then we all vetted the
review of course but uh yeah I mean you
might be wondering why attend is number
five yeah well these are the collective
you know lists and opinions of the
entire GameSpot team yeah so if you're
doing the math there's two other ten on
at ends this year maybe they're in the
top five maybe they're gonna be seen at
all if you're doing the math again
there's probably other ones that aren't
tens that are in the top five but uh
yeah anyway John Luke's IP and Ben Jenga
you both like this game a lot oh yeah
yes um you have we're gonna in a little
bit if you're watching us a lot I'm
gonna be doing a livestream just playing
through a co-op campaign save that you
have in single-player but what is it
about it's been an original sin to that
kind of harkens back to the like glory
days of computer RPGs John Luke uh yeah
I mean a lot of people have been like
Brook claiming this is like the
successor to pull this gate which is
weird because I think there's been like
20 boulders dates over the last like ten
years but I think this game pushes that
forward by it's gonna sound weird but
like accessible I think this game is
actually like pretty accessible compared
to most computer RPGs especially the
more hardcore wines like wasteland 2
that have kind of come out and are
trying to like appeals to those people
like I feel like this is like a really
good way to get in and yeah a lot of it
is just um the fact that the game is a
lot more about like experimentation in
the way you can kind of like interact
with its systems and its world like you
know this has kind of been like a weird
year for like immersive Sims and in
terms of like you know letting the
player use their imagination interact
and this game really just like to kind
of like do whatever you can try weird
stuff and it just works yeah you're
saying this is the closest that you
remember a game getting to like the
freedom of imagination that Dungeons &
Dragons has totally yeah like all these
games try and be Dungeons & Dragons you
know they they use like the D&D type
systems
dice rolls initiative but this is a game
that for that feels like it actually has
like that limitless
potential yeah that look at Dungeons and
Dragons has like obviously you will hit
a barrier at a certain point but just
there are so many variety of like ways
you can solve a quest or just kind of go
do what you want and I think a lot of
that also is because you can play pool
game co-op and then a lot of it becomes
like your personal story with the people
you're playing with like me and Ben
we've been playing a co-op game and I
say we like most of the stories we talk
about aren't even related to the
dialogue which is very good I think the
yeah narrative is great but like a lot
of it's just like our own personal
stories about how we interacted with
that story yeah
Ben you or you always talked about like
some of these crazy stories you've had
in the game we will get more into the
writing that Larian has done on their
part but as far as how the characters
interact in this game and how all the
you know like the lack of boundaries
that gentleman was talking about how
does it contribute to the stories that
you take from it after playing for
however many hours you played so I
really like the the amount of freedom
that they give you in terms of like
actually role-playing the character that
you want to roleplay
they have a really good tagging system
that can change and evolve through your
actual playthrough so if you play
someone who is more of a villain or a
hero it will actually unlock the ability
to have that as a dialogue tree yeah and
there are consequences to everything
that you do and in everything that you
kind of use those on yeah I also like
how even like was it right at the
beginning of the game it's at one of the
first stories that John Luke and I had
we we'd come across the first person you
can recruit to your party the red prince
and John Luke is sitting there talking
to him there he is on the screen we were
talking to him and John the kid almost
recruit him to our party and I had
taught my character to use telepathy and
I was really excited in throwing boxes
everywhere and I picked up a seashell
and I accidentally dragged it to him and
I actually hit him in the face with it
they got very upset like the impatient
child that is just hovering in the
background all their parents that's a
theme through our playthrough which may
be good or bad depending on how you look
at it but John's put up with it which is
great but he got upset and said he was
gonna kill us so we had to kill him and
we had a moment where we paused the game
we're like guys do eat do we want to
like actually murder this man or do we
want to go back
I can try to actually recruit him and it
was really interesting that we kind of
all together as a group were like let's
just kill him and roll on with our story
he was a main party member for me he was
one of my main people like I gave him
most of my good armor and weapons today
like 20 hours but the game is so
fantastic and it's writing in the way
that it encouraged you to this roll with
the punches and kind of accept the
consequences and use that to contribute
to the story gentle I Q had mention kind
of like the fact that there are very few
boundaries that you bump up against that
kind of helps that experimentation did
you find that was constant throughout
your entire playthrough oh yeah I mean
like that is like the way we've been
playing the game is basically like we're
gonna we're gonna try and do the right
thing and then very quickly it doesn't
go well and then we I don't think we've
ever actually like rolled back a save as
far as yeah like you know we were back
sometimes if it's like we died in combat
but never like a choice we just kind of
like live with him we're like well I
guess that guy's dead now and yeah
failed that quest and that person's
crying over there and know whatever it's
so impressive how the game rather than
in a lot of role-playing games recently
modern role-playing games I feel like
they're allowing me to influence the
game and the story but in this one it's
always impressive how these quality of
the story and the game itself influences
my decision-making like I will adapt and
say oh maybe my character would do this
like I had I didn't under and you know
like early on you could put a bucket on
your head for a helmet but it also
covers up the fact that I'm undead so
people don't run and scream for me and
Rob who sits next to me at work saw me
take it off like what the menu was up on
my inventory and I took it off and in
the background you can see this little
kid who was talking to me start
sprinting away undead character but I
then some flight from then on I just my
character became just like bumbling
idiot even though like he was pretty
good throughout the game once I actually
increased his stats for combat whatnot
but I just kind of always saw am I
giving character as the comic relief and
I played into that rather than trying to
change that throughout the playthrough
and the writing itself on Larian Studios
part but it's so fantastic with between
dialogue and voice acting like
throughout the entire game would you
agree with that - oh definitely uh it's
really impressive that I was talking
about the difference and choices that
you can have before all of them are all
voice acted out with like the same
amount of quality throughout the entire
thing yeah you can you can play
Joker you can play a weird person and I
I also like how through the story even
though you're playing co-op they're the
kind of like they're these moments where
they make you split off from your group
and you get told kind of like your
personal story and it kind of leads you
in a separate way even though you're
supposed to be co-opting with these
people and to have it kind of like it's
a really interesting dynamic and I don't
want to get too into spoilery stuff but
it's kind of interesting and you kind of
get like this like oh I learned a thing
that my friends don't know and I didn't
want to tell them because it'll change
how they might perceive how I'm playing
the game yeah so like as we're playing
there's there's weird things that I'm
doing and Jean doesn't know why I'm
doing them because I choose to kind of
keep it to my character
yeah Jake Decorah texted me he's like
he's like doing five hours in and my
main characters been in jail this whole
time I'm using my other three I don't
know how to break him out and I think
finally he got a power that allowed him
to kill somebody to get a key or maybe
he just developed lock-picking skills
enough to break out his cohort but that
was kind of a constant throughout my
game as well I was actually I was
splitting up and like finding the
characters would adapt to situations
definitely uh there's Elf stabile
however you say her name and then the
red prince both had beef with this one
other lizard he's kind of like a dream
Walker he can see yeah like he can use
people's dreams or memories to like kind
of tell their future something I like
Claire he's clairvoyant and Sabeel
wanted to kill him but I didn't realize
that at first so you have a choice to
let her go speak to him alone so at that
point I'm like okay I don't know whether
it trust her but I'll let her go talk to
him and next thing I know she killed him
and then the red prince is like what the
[ __ ] I don't like I needed that guide
for like to tell me what my destiny was
but it's really funny how everything
just interweaves but then of course we
haven't even talked about like the
combat of the game which in itself is
very deep and complex if you played
divinity original sin the first one on
Xbox one
after it was ported from PC even like
it's the amount of options there kind of
reflects the Dyne dynamics of the
conversation and the story because
between elemental things just like weird
things like you like if you're in a pool
of blood you can Electrify it which of
course like I wouldn't do in real world
yeah who would think of runs across
puddles of blood to begin with yeah but
yeah but
there's only when you're playing the
combat this game did you find that there
were like just as many options to
experiment oh yeah I mean in so as an
archer I had this ability called
elemental arrows where I can take
anything that's an elemental on the
ground around me and turn my arrows into
that gives me standing in it or just not
just near it so it's been like five six
feet so I can take that like electric
blood and then apply that to my arrows
and now I have like arrows that do like
bleeding damage and shock damage so you
could have like a teammate electrify the
blood and then you get the electricity
from the button exactly that's awesome
yeah you know there's like tactics you
don't even think of like okay there's
fire we can get rid of the fire but then
when you get rid of the fire with like a
rain spell it creates steam which
actually creates like good cover so it's
like okay people can't really like shoot
through it and you can hide in it yeah
or use it as a way to like flank an
enemy and so yeah like a lot of it's
just like experimentation and bouncing
off of each other we were doing some
really good combos yesterday yeah yeah
we were in a really volatile situation
where there was just a bunch of oil and
of course when you see while you're like
imma set it on fire mm-hmm that's a very
bad idea don't recommend it but we're
being really tactical about our choices
and stuff and we were like oh let's put
out the fire because it's everywhere now
we can't get anywhere but wait if we do
that it'll create steam we will know
well not have a line of sight on
anything anymore to actually hit it yeah
and it's it's kind of cool to think
about that type of stuff and even in the
clip we were just showing like outside
of the elemental effects again being
really excited about telepathy I
actually moved a fire barrel next to
what we were gonna fight while I was
like hidden inside of a bush yeah you
can prepare for them and then John Luke
like shot it and set it on fire and then
it alligator was on fire and it was a
good way to start off the fight yeah you
can yeah you can set up ambushes and
whatnot cuz like I'm like many
turn-based games or I mean because this
goes back to many computer RPGs you know
like you don't go to a separate screen
for the fight it's actually just takes
place on the same part of the map that
you were just walking up to so you can
set up ambushes once you start to see
how the system works and you can have
like your archer up here on the dock if
you're watching this around that wooden
scaffolding then you can have your rogue
kind of waiting to dash in at the last
second to get the last kill but it's
just so it's um
using that in a game like this the
combat is just as deep as the story and
the dialogue or vice-versa
it's amazing that the dialogue is as
dynamic as the combat it's fantastic to
see but jean-luc what like after you're
looking back at this game they're out
the month since its released what is it
that really stuck with you what is it
that keeps you playing this game for me
it's definitely playing it with been
like me my Ben and my brother I've been
playing with them and just like having
something every weekend to just like sit
down and we'll play for a couple hours
and have like this shared experience of
like weird stories is just like it is
that DND type experience but then you
have you know like this by being a
computer game it's much more accessible
like it's you can have like this visual
element to it I mean we didn't even talk
about that the game actually has like a
DMD mode yeah go for it which is really
cool I got to check it out before the
game came out and that is like that is
the actual like basically they created
like a full-on like if you just want to
play a day into you campaign you can do
that where you can like set up a bunch
of scenarios and maps and you can kind
of create your own like the game has a
really good mod tool with like Steam
Workshop but then as the dungeon master
you have the ability to like at any
points like Oh I'll pause it and I'll
move these characters around and sort of
the they just give you like a really
good tool set to like let the other
players like use their imagination and
that's that's probably a little bit more
hardcore like trying to get that
together is a little bit more complex
than Jeff yeah well let's play the main
campaign together but the fact that they
have that as an option I think is like
the coolest thing then Janka what about
you what is this stuck with you about
this game throughout the months since it
came out just it's the stories I I loved
coming into the office and telling
people about like I had this really cool
moment where the another one of my
favorite ones that happen kind of midway
through playing one of my own games when
I was playing as the beast he's like a
pirate and he's supposed to be kind of
like rough around the edges and kind of
cool like that so he he walked up to
this guy he was really sad because my
son died trying to defend our town from
these bandits out outside and his
weapons broken and it's useless now and
I can't bring myself to fix it so I had
a character moment specifically for the
Beast where he could grab the
sword kind of I had a bit and then he
just like breaks down the edge of a
table and he's like look it's serrated
now it'll do more damage than it did
before get your stuff together and like
go fight and he's like oh I'm really
happy now I'm gonna go fight all these
dudes and avenge my son and I was like
that's that's great yeah and this was
completely aside from like jean-luc and
his brother were off doing some
completely different and I got to have
that that like moment even aside from
everything else we were doing yeah it's
just I love all the stories that you can
kind of run into and share with people
yeah the amount of experimentation and
possibilities that this game allows for
is pretty daunting but like that's
probably why I have such a lasting
appeal that is divinity original sin to
one of the three ten on the tens on the
GameSpot scale this year which means
it's essential which means you should
definitely try it out no matter who you
are and it is number five on our top ten
of the Year list so in a year of unreal
releases this was in the GameSpot staffs
opinion one of the best of the best just
to reiterate every weekday leading up
till Wednesday so tomorrow and then
Wednesday at 10 a.m. Pacific we will be
announcing tomorrow our number four game
and then Wednesday we'll have a mega
stream or pretty much going three to one
right in a row all in one stream but
they'll go about an hour and a half two
hours so we're not completely sure yet
but please join us and then if you're
watching this live now we are about to
livestream
divinity original sin too but if you're
watching this on youtube or games by
after-the-fact go catch up with all
those games if you have time go maybe
play what remains to be the Finch which
got our number nine you can do that in
the sitting or hell-blade in two
sittings or finish off horizon zero dawn
or Wolfenstein two and then come back
and join us tomorrow or Wednesday or
whenever it may be thanks for joining
but if you're still watching this live
we're about to play the video original
sin 2 right now so this is the campaign
you guys are talking about or it's not
save from that campaign but gently
you're gonna be playing its
single-player yeah Peter do you want to
the volume from I would love to Joel
okay yeah so this is you guys said about
20 hours is about 20 hours in we're in
the the second act here it's real big
right now in a graveyard
so after you've escaped fork/join gone
through the swamps mm-hm and then this
is the next area or is there like
another one between there that I'm not
remembering
oh just as a spoiler alert I don't think
we'll touch any major plot points but I
guess if you want to go into the game
not knowing where you
might go in the world or right what kind
of powers you might get I guess yes joy
this is like the next big area this list
is like way bigger than for joy there's
so much to do
oh I thought that was for joy off to the
west no no no no okay hold anything
reaper so this is our playthrough that
we've been playing so i only know how to
play one of these characters I might
have it sorry I've played a wizard a bit
so I might be able to help you there and
I've been playing my guys so you can
take a cop game and play it on your own
mm-hmm again you can jump in jump out of
single-player campaigns to as I want to
say there were some weird limitations
where like it knows that it's a that
that's like I'm meant to be a player
character so it doesn't catch it like I
don't think you can have the like the
dialogue stuff with them that you would
have if you were playing a single player
like companion dialogue right what oh
there's a there's a dude decide that
guys so there's a great example of how
random things can happen no funny
business burn in who do we got who is it
see like in this game this could be a
whole new playable character even like
the narrations that dialogue is not
amazing but there I love the Marigny
he's so good it's this game is very very
funny which we didn't touch on but it is
worth noting oh shoot dude
he took up a philosophy crisping the
philosopher so quite we dig you up
what no idea where this can go for it
yeah my characters a little bit of a
show-off go for it when you're human our
rope here
it's he's actually playing Llosa yeah
buying an Origin Colonel you did one of
that yeah we all take the origin
characters cuz we just kind of wanted to
experience that like extra bit of story
stuff you yet you're stuck to the
skeleton now all right we're just
starting the screen with a battle of
wits jester might have a jester option
are you the others here humor yeah my
characters uh she's an actual Joker yeah
boom funny and she all right like that
answer
yeah I doing this
back again shivering oh shoot you're
making this Skelton get really
existential hey how are you not
essential here got skeletons yeah I feel
like that's a thing you need the gods
guide I'm also a mystic which is a weird
combo yeah right ooh three is a good
answer that kind of encapsulates a game
he's making this guy feels yeah no I see
what you mean just popping out of the
ground he's he's really excited about
this know this origin character that
you're playing I don't think I've met
her yet
oh yes what's she on the ship the
beginning she's on the ship mister her
whole thing is like she's a wandering
minstrel who has like a like like a
Lovecraftian being stuck inside of her
Henderson yeah yeah like what can it
take over during combat sometimes to a
certain certain story beats I've had it
where it like I I ended up having to
like fight a bunch of people and they
had to fight me that was a - it was
really cool
moral immoral it's not so easily define
wait take your finding you have your
finger so you touched his rib I guess
that's how he's like locking you into
the question I can question zone it's an
organ that most of us don't have I'm
sure I have I've got to have some perma
white he's come running back out them
hey I'm done with you go away we can
kill him or can you kill him there's
some there's some good dogs around here
you could talk to there are that's
Gregor that's real creepy it's got some
some cool stuff
one thing I should activate is a spirit
vision so you get this ability where you
can communicate with spirits including
people you recently killed in combat oh
it's fun cuz I get real mad that you
learned there's a lizard wizard right in
front of you get that feel quick back
story about else so if people aren't
confused Oh Elvis can consume our
cannibals essentially in this game or
they eat other people to some people to
get their memories yeah yeah she can
like learn abilities and stuff by eating
someone's leg so naturally you need to
go right for the chest which is what
most memories restore life of course she
might be talking about an actual chest
because there is an actual like chest up
there huh I could be wrong I don't know
yeah yeah I can consume her spirit if I
want you already full upon source yeah I
haven't I have no reason to do it that's
a source you have to those are the two
blue things on your health yeah to
charge source points which you can use
for special abilities and I'll take
a chunk and you can get it back by
finding in through source pools or you
can like consume me
did I say guys I took 10 hours to
finally remove my collar in this game
really yeah oh so it was actually a cool
thing that I discovered during our
playthrough but I won the the arena
event in Fort joy and they took mine off
like in the first five hours that's how
you get it taken off winning the arena
event so it's another person that knows
how they work
oh man yeah there's like a person who's
like oh you're the arena champion I'm
gonna take your collar off for you just
don't get seen by the guards yeah and
then I got seen by the guards and then
we had to do a whole bunch of murders
yeah okay so we're trying to get to
trying to find this object for this guy
I've been there yeah classic video game
so can we need a finally so weird thing
for the skeleton to say um I found that
key somewhere in here I'm just trying
remember I think it was inside of one of
the things Oh
- more like a few years ago when every
RPG had that fetch quest that was making
fun of fetch quests yeah as if that was
the end of fetch quest yeah yeah even
though we joked about it I think there's
something that happens over here you go
find that dog thanks so much
oh you picked the lock right over there
over here
oh this fight yeah should do this one
this is a good one Wow us alright oh
there's there's a good day oh you have a
pet animal
speech language Oh
you in a white and green that's worth
noting for those who don't know that
extra views editor Kevin been ordered
played a big part in writing this game
specifically the dwarf character oh
really
oh yeah he's really good he's like a
door this door character yeah the Beast
I believe is one of my play fees I made
it and actually played through but I
only got I got about 20 hours in but I
was only in the swamps and with my
undead but then I played the door I did
I didn't do any origin characters and
dorks are pretty funny in this they are
Stroup like
press for information because he's a dog
does that mean he peed on it
No anything's possible keeping it classy
are you starting a fight yeah
may I think I might what it yeah yeah
yeah he's making the ground shake
beneath her feet ever the first time we
did this really yeah the dog is very
serious and that you'll see that he's
just someone to giant bone gone but
that's fine okay well so we're right on
top of him that's good dad
living up to what she usually does she's
taking a lot of damage I might have not
is everything okay in the kitchen
something bone columns again oh you know
Chris Maya you're really weird this year
god this would be a really fun thing to
do Christmas morning just settle in and
play a bunch of divinity yeah thank you
I friend back I go home Thursday morning
I think and uh my friends back home who
want to play this well they've been
playing it but I have to play much co-op
any morning let's see the highly
recommend playing co-op if you can
can get into this with my brother and my
nephew PC also I know I have to figure
out how to play these even though on our
playthrough were doing mostly on like
the normal difficulty it's still kind of
difficult it's like if you want to have
a good time and like do some some rad
roleplay stuff and like make people
laugh there's no shame in putting on
Explorer right it's it's a good time
game takes on a new life exactly they
perfectly valid like oh yeah I like
Explorer mode same maybe it was because
I didn't take my collar off so I
couldn't use its going to throw someone
some rocks down there you go yeah with
them rocks he's a lot of everything it's
okay he's got he's got oil underneath
him knows you set him on fire oh hey
guys got most characters I've magic too
well not most character but many cares
have met how do i do you want to like at
all you want Dooku like a like an all-in
kind of all right so what you want to do
is you want to hit that uh bad that that
little like purple icon third one from
the right over there you go that one hit
that okay it'll boost your damage all
right then you want hit it's three yeah
I believe and then you pick the thing
you want to teleport behind it you're
gonna you followed up with a - okay
where you throw your daggers even though
they're right next to it it's a good
idea ch and then if you want to rupture
with four yes yes I do
there we go yeah your attendance that
sounds awful yeah it's real bad so the
the good like one-two combo is you
rupture tendons and then you turn them
into a chicken yes yeah being a chicken
forces you to walk around and rupture
tendons makes it so it hurts whenever
you walk oh I never considered that way
but I do the oh yeah charge into
something
three three wanted out charge I'm gonna
try kill the dog there we go oh geez
solve our problems oh boy that Bogle
just said no knocks you right down wet
geez yeah at least selling something a
couple of skeleton boys oh man
damn and there she goes yep that's
that's totally par for the course for
civil yeah that's classic that's several
yeah so you can customize the money I
mean made her look yeah later on you get
a mirror that lets do like respec and
change your appearance she does the
other thing if cool if you're afraid of
where you've gotten with your character
stat-wise you can completely reroll then
when you get to the second act which is
definitely good no I almost never
respect characters in any RPG but almost
never you're one of those guys writer
diet you yeah but I need to be there the
whole process to like understand their
build I can't just like make the build
and then five minutes later get into a
fight with it that's totally totally
legitimate I mean it's a I get why
people do it like often yeah it I think
it's more like oh no I didn't realize
that ones were considered one-handed
weapon yeah so I should put all my stuff
into Wands instead of my character has
dueling poison wands it's a good way to
do it except for in here the poisons are
not good thing when you're in here okay
where's that sulphur spill
well also because my
I have two undead characters my main
character and then what's that undead
character's name Fame so feign has the
dual wielding poison wands so they're
also healing sticks for my undead
character because poison heals undead
yeah so used to classic strategy we like
to use as we like to teleport enemies
really far away and so we just
teleported him behind this gate so he's
gonna have to go like all the way around
mm-hmm we're just gonna give us at least
like two turns without him in the
picture that'd be funny if he just
casually open the doors like you know I
live here right shoot the last time to
teleport someone was the dog well that's
so that's why I did not teleport the dog
because that was a mistake yeah yeah
some real gross sounds what is that slug
thing under the dead spirit what
oh it's a classic goop monster yeah Oh
bloated corpse ooh
you can use like it's a necromancy spell
where you can turn a corpse into like a
moving thing then it'll like explode
okay
real gross okay hey deal with this dog I
wish nothing with any of these al is
Ruiz always so we're not doing hot here
can you do laser is that I can usually
you'll hit him with the laser it's cool
spell not the best thing you use that
but it's really cool that spoke so
highly of it before we started oh never
mind the dog the dog doesn't have hands
so the Golem has hands and he might be
able to open the game he's also twice
the size of the door well that I really
thought you could stop me
I don't say this fight it's not going
very well no this is the trend for most
of our Jake went into some of the
hardest fights in horizon during oh yeah
that was a time to watch we have brushes
towards the river
anytime he's near oh wow he almost
killed the t-rex at the end after
killing some of those larger
pterodactyls it's fine that's a okay
[Music]
well that was a bad time there was a lot
fire in that picture yeah that was last
night
did you play this last night yeah yeah
we're playing some mystery it was a was
a rough time you guys should live stream
because I would like to just watch you
guys play yeah I'm in sign me up let's
do it
started your email credentials and your
twitch account your send you my social
security by the end of the day I already
got that oh yeah we're good perfect the
only problem is it could be this game is
a lot of waiting especially when you're
playing co-op where you're just like
waiting for that one person be like what
spell do I want that's where the real
answer comes into play low yeah that's
when you get the timer out of the room
that's when I put on a silly hat what
game is it has timers [ __ ] pick up
there you got and your turn get out of
here yeah what is that one that one that
has the time no sorry doesn't know sorry
sorry timers would be a heck of a thing
Connect four I think is what you're
thinking you should just get a DND die
the 20-sided one assignee twenty years
to all that yeah pick it that way it
could be Indian side use your
resurrection scroll no it's dead I can't
do it I've already done the thing with
Gareth yeah probably not and this uh I
don't think so they should make a game
that you can like literally roll a die
under camera and it'll like pick up the
dots and tell you that that would be
cool only cool alright that's my next
career move an event that no one was
watching steal this
wait we're live-streaming oh yeah I
can't be bothered this vision there's a
lot in that book there's a lot in that
book
what are those possible quests laughs it
was close quest if it's finished ones
there's just no shame if you want a bump
it down soon I already owe your dude
don't worry
fantastic Oh shame here a plug trying to
do without people noticing pen where'd
you totally bumped it up it's it's good
to go so we're playing on the highest
difficulty now I'm kidding we're not if
we die it deletes our save oh yeah if
you are interested in trying to scheme
out or if you played a lot of it saved
you it did a good video unlike this why
it made him fall back in love with
old-school RPGs I think he spent
something like 15 hours in the first
area this is not lick that door most
patriotic thing you bet see that Hawk on
the way to work if you guys walk down
second Street I was walking down there's
a crowd of people on the corner making a
circle and I look there's just uh
there's just a hawk just see on the
sidewalk on the sidewalk and there's
just a bunch of people crying around
taking photos of it it's probably
injured that's real bad yeah oh geez
nothing I love there's there's actually
hawks in the like novel Tenderloin area
it didn't seem I don't know so I didn't
look at it too long but it was standing
up and it was just kind of looking
around it didn't look like you my
existence I'm a predator like that
wouldn't just Oh chill down there for
it's just a street Hawk for loose change
shoulda known Street hound but no one
was like suction or anything which was
good but it was the way but still it was
chilling though here I probably was
injured after that cannabis dispensary
real early this morning
so this this is a good time to mention
two of my favorite things about this guy
the music the music so do like a banjo
kazooie kind of thing where most of the
music is the same theme just played
differently to kind of a company
wherever you are
banjo tooie do that as well better I
don't think so I think you might be
confused there's ghosts there
yeah something it's like this piano that
plays but uh with spirit
did you just cast it's called the see
spirits reveal find the piano player
spook me with ghosts did we talk to this
person
no oh geez I only learned about this
later
Oh direct them Oh tell her to play it's
all star by smashmouth yo you take
requests you know we can there's mods in
this game because we can mod it oh my
god and every theme is just a different
weird version of all-star
instead of the divinity somebody was
playing Smash Mouth very loudly through
their car at like 11 o'clock
look I'm sorry where yes I'd sometimes I
just like to joy it around San Francisco
and bless all star I live your best life
game alright we like steal anything here
oh the composer for a banjo pericope mmm
they'd like most rare games well david
wise was the other donkey kong's yeah
yeah well that's a good thing touch on
that ghost moose I don't know good
there's a good news I tried
whoa what is this
well it's producing a batch - don't say
we did not see any look we walked into
here talk to the guy and he gave us a
job and then we left
yeah so take care of this deer for me
this moose oh yeah okay always consume
sorcerer's that's something you unlocked
no that's always it's a thing that
happens after a story point yeah we also
have um source of vampirism so you can
steal it from a living character which
is really funny because you just steal
from your party members yeah and then
just revive them right after
no they just you took their source point
they don't have anymore oh I thought you
consume them as well now you can you can
fight each other go sneak downstairs see
what's going on down here
alright sweet we held off on doing this
before so take a big spanking thing that
hawk was he was dank this morning I woke
up with the dinosaur down there Eddie
Betty who talked to Betty what's going
on [ __ ] you want
console' that turtle just that turtle on
the lips that's that is very in his I'm
smushed like three spiders is it it's
been a real rough time for him there's
that which you run into kind of early in
the game who like seduces people and
most of the dialogue options like go
right into it
yeah you for most like three out of four
options every time are pretty much
giving in and then like the last one is
resist as hard as you can but then it
still kind of happens like you've been
real right away yeah those like you're
offering smooches I'm down and then she
made me really sick okay this Turtles
come along with me um I hope I get an
option does a special turtle yeah so
she's trying to come to that retracted
whoa tell her you like turtles
then I yeah the one once let's hook this
up what
what should we let her continue cheese
juice know this cheese she was just milk
no hot I don't know it's really she's
uses a very unpleasant who's hurt
herself no I just talked about the rat
but no she called the radical er didn't
she she wants me to cheese juice her
okay right that's great we're gonna save
here they're up in the air you can see
them on the map oh right yeah up in the
dungeon as a person constantly looking
for animals to talk to rats are alarming
thank you
they're very small that's Betty's
biggest problems oh yeah come slow down
yeah okay so it seems like we have to
give him food yeah we want to give him
some food here oh check the image I know
I have food in my inventory that arrived
a fantastic attract third from the
bottom
have a fantastic collection of expensive
wines you got to get any cheese I would
assume yeah let's see what we got here
give him one of everything
sorry the wrath I use some pumpkin soup
potato some hams we got cheese cheese
breads got cheese in it I guess get to
drop it for him just put it on the floor
here
what
just give them give actual cheese more
stuff just keep throwing it at him give
him a whole watermelon seeds are
poisonous to rest
does anybody have cheese in their
inventory hope you got watermelon maybe
if they get into a certain what do you
think ham can do in the pie next can you
feed it man another rat that's on fire
up by the potato why do I have a chunk
of flesh in my inventory who gave this
Americo that's never mine where the rock
out Marius OOP Joey's into that okay fan
has a bunch of food to it does anybody
have cheese how can you be hungry it's
gotta be cheese telling you he's eaten
so much food that was bread that's not
the same it's cheap Alex Wyse there's a
bunch of beer yeah that's yep I'm really
I'm waiting for you to accidentally drop
it on him and kill him
cuz that that was real close can you do
that yeah it's fine you know that's
that's cool Wow check veins in its
feeding I'm really glad you some of into
my collection that I have that's about
sack you know was that yours or is that
mine it's mine just Sabeel have anything
cheesy down one a little more she's got
some bread some bread fries fries that's
pretty good eat the fries you see okay
we gave you got do you feel like it oh
wait that's cuz I talked
oh why so this is a perfect opportunity
then we can
go get cheese yeah I feel the square
here who sells cheese in the market yeah
let's find some people this guy's let's
buy a [ __ ] ton of it
yeah let's build a giant like a cheese
fort what do you think self cheese the
fish dude might have some some food
stuff what a cheapskate can't believe
this the tavern get some cheese at its
having probably or worst case just get
into a fight in the tavern we can listen
to that awesome fight music I'm very
concentrated I'm hooking that turtle and
rat up yeah that's our goal
it's a good goal oh yeah they're still
knocked out from this drinking contest
you had yeah you bet you're doing yeah
they're like I bet I could drink you
under the table you gross door I was
like try me grapes didn't the turtle
mention a few other foods that he likes
or something good by snares may a carrot
Thurs
lissa deuce to youth yeah those are like
a juicer can find a juicer
my name is pretty good uh whistles that
was next 42 goals were eliminated it's
hard it's hard times and uh Rulon now
all right someone's gotta have cheese
and driftwood yeah cheese tail like a
dedicated cheese cheese peddler yeah
it's a spell boy I just felt like the
cheese spell spell spell that just makes
cheese fall pretty good yeah this place
all fish it is a port town no cows to be
seen most pumpkin in there and she's
used stolen
oh it's everyone's gold like there for
you to see how do we craft some cheese
all right might be out of luck and have
to leave this yeah dang dang dang well
at least you at least you know you can
hook up a turtle and exactly all right
you want to do or definitely overnight
we try another combat yeah let's get
into one quick Oh ice cream good you
want to do a bar fight do bar fight go
just cause general ruckus we don't have
to actually like win yeah that's right
well or maybe we will
it's a bunch of drunk people in a bar
even elf assassin an undead necromancer
yep a dwarven warrior and a possessed
Archer and you can't win a bar fight
Archer bharden I'm uh my career as a
famous
it's like Taylor Swift all three are
fighting in the shoe just stand on the
table that guy's actually singing a song
about my well that guy's warm by you
Foster stall right here oh you get
started here yeah I'm done
how do you start just like do a flame
wave Wow and the man in the back oh this
this is that that fight you know I got
this charm arrow one of these fires you
can get eyes turning or it just turns
them to the side for how long uh that's
a turn but you can boost him up
buh-buh-buh-buh jeez leave some for the
rest of us
and peace of mind on him guy's name is
Stu oh yeah so if you really want to you
can go into a bar and kill a whole bunch
of people and has no effect on anything
you just continue on well I could have
an effect if some of those people are
attached to a quest true they're not
important in here
forget is he saying so I was a glorious
my character as I'm shooting him yeah
Oh what instrument did you pick for the
playthrough so I think I picked the
cello at first but then I picked up a
loop I found with a loop having the loot
in my inventory and actually changed my
song for those watching if you have
played you can pick an instrument that
like is your character's theme I think I
think the lute as well you do a lute a
cello okay what else can you do a
mandolin kind of faces there's like two
other instruments I've never heard of
and I'm pretty sure they're made of but
they're probably super like a but I like
a something like that yeah yeah yeah
Bowron it home no serious that handheld
drum with a two-sided and stick that you
hit it with all right that guy's dead
perfect so what she wants to kill
someone she's real good at killing
someone absolutely
okay you'll pick up that table and throw
it at someone you just click on it and
drag it I think that's fine all right
it's okay that's the one thing is it's
easy to play accidentally click the
wrong thing and you can't like undo that
it just kind of sucks
all right this seems like a probably a
good spot to call it sure all right
sweet well thank you for everybody
joining John Luke and Ben thank you for
showing us divinity original sin to our
number-5 game of 2017 a lot of fantastic
games came out this year but this was
one of the best of the best again it was
a 10 out of 10 on gamespot which means
you should go try it a lot of us think
it's a masterpiece I'm Larian Studios
part from Belgium sequel to their
already fantastic divinity original sin
4
three years ago when I at this point and
then it came to Xbox one the following
year yeah but yeah again every tomorrow
and Wednesday at 10:00 a.m. Pacific we
are going to be announcing tomorrow's
our number-four game and then Wednesday
at 10:00 a.m. Pacific we're gonna start
a longer stream where we announced three
to one in the same stream thank you so
much for joining us today you can go
catch up another game of the Year stuff
if you haven't for our ten through six
games and hopefully catch up on these
before we get to our number for tomorrow
but in the meantime thank you so much
for joining and we'll see you then